what's up guys my name is welcome back
to my Ray tracing Series so last time we
rented multiple spheres we now have
support for rendering multiple spheres
inside our scene which is pretty cool
because we can start to actually build
up something nice that video will be
linked up there of course if you haven't
seen it you can check it out today we're
going to have some fun and we're going
to plan for the future that's always fun
right we're going to take our existing
renderer class and completely
restructure it we're going to make it
work in a way that is very similar to
how a GPU Ray tracing pipeline works so
if you're familiar with Vulcan Ray
tracing or drag text 12 Ray tracing
we're basically going to emulate that to
some degree within our CPU based
renderer why are we doing this well when
I was thinking about what I want to do
with this series I realized that
obviously the end goal is in fact doing
real-time Ray tracing on the GPU using
Vulcan it is going to be quite a big
change if we just go from a full like
CPU optimized Ray Tracer to now a GPU
raytracer I want to kind of strike a
balance between the two and because I I
quite like the way that the ray tracing
pipelines work in Vulcan and DirectX 12
I thought we might as well just
Implement them here whilst it may not be
like the most efficient and optimal way
to write a CPU like a CPU only Ray
Tracer I think it will be fast enough
it's not gonna it's not gonna damage our
performance or our code too much it's
just going to be more or less like a
layout and organization kind of thing
okay so let's dive into the code and
take a look at how this is going to work
now in terms of how Vulcan Ray tracing
works I'm going to save that explanation
for when we start doing that obviously
so don't expect that here today if we go
into our renderer class at the moment
what happens is we call this render
function and then what that does is it
goes through every single Pixel of the
image we're trying to render and casts
out array we then call this Trace Ray
color per pixel which returns a color
value back to us now there's a few
problems with this first of all this is
under the assumption that we want to
really only Trace like a single Ray per
pixel and that every that we Trace is
going to provide us with a color that's
not really correct for a few reasons we
usually want to cast more than one rate
per pixel and like there's a few
different levels to this for one we
might be doing multi-sampling so maybe
we want to gather a few different
samples and form one pixel which will
give us some nice anti-aliasing but also
even if we're not talking about that we
want to bounce Rays around if array is
coming in from the camera and hits the
surface over here we definitely need to
bounce array somewhere not just if this
is actually a reflective surface and
thus we need to draw a reflection here
but if we're just trying to do some
basic like diffuse lighting like some
Global illumination we need to make sure
that we actually sample the light from
various directions that might be hitting
this surface we'll get into Global
elimination and all that stuff later in
this series of course but for now just
know that when the ray actually comes
from the camera and hits this object
here we need to bounce additional Rays
from that hit position another great
example of having to cast more than one
Ray per pixel is if we hit a surface and
we need to determine whether or not it's
in Shadow the way we do that is we might
cast array from the hit position to our
light source so the ray comes from the
camera it hits this point over here we
need to know whether or not that's in
Shadow so we just cast array from that
point into the light like directly to
the light if it's a directional light
then just in the light Direction with
like infinite distance if it's a point
light then just like to the point lines
position if that Ray misses everything
so it doesn't hit anything we know where
not in Shadow we're in light because we
have direct non-occluded Vision to the
light otherwise if it hits another
object in the way then we know that
we're in Shadow we need to be able to
support all of these things and that
requires a little bit of restructuring
so what I want to do is I actually want
to take what we've got over here and
break it up into a few different
functions I want to handle all of the
different cases of what happens to our
Rays such as if we miss all the objects
so we don't hit anything but also the
closest hit object as well I want to
separate that into and actually function
I want to separate this Trace Ray
function so that it's responsible for
just tracing array and then providing us
with some sort of payload depending on
like if it hits an object or if it
misses everything entirely and I also
want to write a per pixel function that
is just simply going to be a function
that's going to be called once for every
iteration of this for Loop so let's go
ahead and get started whilst doing this
I'm also going to draw some parallels
into GPU side Ray tracing so first the
per pixel function now I think I'm going
to call this per pixel but really what
this is is a raygen Shader so in Vulcan
and DirectX 12 this is known as a raygen
Shader this gets invoked for every pixel
we're trying to render and within that
Shader or within this function we can
determine whether or not we want to
potentially cast multiple Rays per pixel
and that's where we actually cast The
Ray so we'll call Trace Ray from within
this function I could call it raygen I'm
not sure if I want to follow those apis
exactly so I think I'll just call it per
pixel because ultimately that makes
sense that makes the most sense to me
now sane and Camera are both objects
that we need access to within like all
of these functions but what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to make the member
variables here instead so that we can
just access them throughout our like
entire pipeline here the way that I want
to do this is by just holding pointers
to our active scene so we'll make this a
const pointer active scene equals null
pointer as well as active camera
and that's obviously going to be a
camera I don't want to make shared
pointers out of this or anything like
that because if you take a look at how
this actually works inside Walnut
app.cpp we at the moment just have these
nice stack allocated objects I don't
want to necessarily Heap allocate them
and then share them into like these
functions and deal with like Atomic
increments and all that stuff it's
completely unnecessary instead what we
can do is just when we actually render
over here we're going to set our active
scene to be the memory address of scene
and then we'll set active camera to be
the memory address of camera now this is
a non-owning like pointer obviously so
in other words if this class dies then
we lose our data but as you can see we
also lose our renderer so the ownership
semantics of this obviously are tied to
this class so there's no way that this
is going to result in like you know us
accidentally frame memory that's in use
or anything like that at least for the
time being okay back to our header file
over here so that way that way our
personal function obviously can have
access to this and then our Trace array
function let's talk about how that's
going to work that's not going to return
a color anymore Instead This is
completely going to be like abstracted
away from the concept of colors Trace
Ray is a function that will shoot array
out into a particular place and from a
particular point so really Ray is the
only thing it will take in and then what
it's actually going to return to us is
some kind of payload now this payload is
just going to be some information about
what happened to our Ray so we traced
array cool but did we hit anything and
if so like what is the hit distance what
is the object that we hit some potential
like attributes about that object as
well all of that is going to be
contained within something called a hit
payload now this is just going to be a
private struct that we have here at
least for now we're going to have a hit
distance inside this struct and then
anything else that you add here is kind
of up to you so we might want to have
like a world normal a world position we
could even have reference to like a
particular sphere that we've hit however
what I think I'll do instead is
potentially have some kind of object
index I'm not initializing any of these
variables and we'll see if we need to
later on so this hit payload is
ultimately what this function will
return for us however the hit payload is
something that we should be able to set
depending on obviously what happens to
the ray so did the ray hit something if
so we need to invoke another function
called closest hit and this represents
the closest hit Shader inside our Ray
tracing pipeline so this will take in
information about the ray as well as
this object index and it will return a
hit payload so this shade is really
going to be responsible this function is
really going to be responsible for
determining the world position and the
world normal now hit distance is also
something that we should probably take
in so I think I'll right float hit
distance this is like ultimately
something that we could package up into
like metadata about the ray itself and
the ray evaluation and we might talk
about that a little bit later but for
now we'll just pass it in like this so
we know that if we hit something we
invoke the closest Head Shadow with the
closest object of the camera that we hit
but what if we've missed everything
completely well what we're going to do
is write another function for that
called Miss and this is going to
represent the Miss Shader inside our Ray
tracing pipeline now it's going to take
in the Ray and that's it there's
obviously no hit distance and there's no
object index so what we can do here is
really anything I mean we could add like
some kind of color to this and return
like our clear color instead what we're
going to do is basically just set here
distance to like negative one or
something like that and that way back in
per pixel where we need to determine a
color we can check to see if Trace Ray
returns a hit payload of a hit distance
of negative one and if so we return our
clear color or some kind of Sky color
something like that okay cool so that is
looking pretty good and that is more
than enough for us to get started now in
the GPU Ray tracing pipeline there are a
few other shaders which we haven't
really implemented here such as the any
head Shader which we might use for like
translucent objects and then also so the
intersection Shader which we would be
using to figure out whether or not we
have hit something but that's kind of
going to be baked into our Trace Ray
function since we are dealing with
spheres in the future with GPU rate
racing will mostly be dealing with
triangles and so we probably wouldn't
even need to use an intersection Shader
however what we're doing here is kind of
rendering these procedural spheres which
would require the use of an intersection
Shader however that's kind of baked into
our Trace array function at the moment
now before we start implementing all
these I want to thank brilliant for
sponsoring this series brilliant is an
amazing website filled with really high
quality courses on various stem topics
such as computer science and math
brilliant have been a really good
sponsor of this series because they're
such a fantastic resource for like all
of the math that you'll need for this
series seriously I can't recommend them
enough I've been using brilliant to
revise heaps of the math that we'll need
for this Theory such as calculus unlike
other potential sources out there the
reason why I love brilliant so much is
because of how Visual and interactive it
is all of their courses have like these
amazing like visual widgets that you can
play with to help you understand what
they're teaching you and they'll also
ask you questions and quiz you to make
sure that you're following along and
actually learning the content this kind
of visual engaging way to learn things
means that you'll actually learn them
and they have a mouth course for like
literally everything calculus algebra
even this new everyday math course which
is great for people who are just getting
into math the best thing about brilliant
is that you can get started for free
just go to brilliant.org the Cherno and
check it out however brilliant have been
nice enough to offer 20 off an annual
membership to the first 200 of my
subscribers who sign up using that link
below so definitely go ahead and check
it out seriously if you're trying to
learn math like you don't know what
you're missing huge thank you to
brilliant as always for sponsoring this
video okay so how do we Implement these
well I'm going to use visual assist by
just right clicking here and going
create method implementations pretty
easy I'm pretty sure Visual Studio can
kind of do the same thing maybe not in
one go Okay cool so we have per pixel we
have Trace Ray I'll just collapse this
for a minute here so that we can think
about how we want to do this a lot of
the functional quality of this random
function we're going to kind of move
into that per pixel function I mean not
not like a lot of it but you can see
that like this is us iterating through
every pixel so ultimately this is where
we want to call per pixel we also have
this kind of Ray and Ray origin being
set here from the camera this obviously
has to do with us calling Trace Ray
which we're going to do from within per
pixel so we'll move that stuff over
there in a minute but per pixel will
return a color so what we need to do is
basically replace this code here with
just per pixel like that and we can
pretty much keep everything else so
redirection and Ray origin
this is the kind of stuff that we
actually need to move into this per
pixel function now the thing is we need
to know which pixel index we're actually
looking at so let's go ahead and move
this and then we'll figure out how we
can do that so inside per pixel this is
what I'm going to write now camera we
know is going to be active camera
so we can change it to be that and we
can do the same thing for our array
directions however X and Y what they're
going to be are the current pixel index
that we're actually looking at now if we
strictly bring this back to like GPU Ray
tracing in Vulcan there's something
called GL underscore launch ID that is
essentially the index of the pixel that
we're currently like processing inside
our rage and Shader and we can use that
as a coordinate to write back into a
texture however we don't really have
that here I don't really feel like
making member variables for that so what
I'm going to do is simply pass in X and
Y into this function here and if we go
back to per pixel we can just type in X
and Y as the parameters over here so
that way we can just pass in X and Y
like that and then we'll have access to
X and Y so that we can for example
calculate our array direction we
obviously don't need X and Y to write
back into the image because that is
something that the per pixel function
doesn't do the pixel function just
returns a color and we actually do that
as part of here might change this in the
future in GPU Ray tracing pipelines you
would be riding into the texture from
your rage and Shader so it would be a
little bit different and when we have to
deal with accumulation and stuff like
that might make more sense to do that
but we will cross that bridge when we
get there I'm kind of enjoying providing
different ways to do this anyway so now
what we can do from per pixel is ideally
call the trace Ray function now it's
changed a little bit what I might do is
I might just change this function to be
our Trace Ray function so let's go ahead
and grab this render a hit payload and
replace the return type here and I'll
delete this other function because this
is what's doing most of the work anyway
okay so last episode we actually
iterated through all of this uh we don't
really need to do this check anyway
because we have a for Loop for that and
we check this anyway although that was a
bit of an early out I guess remember
what we're returning here is the hit
payload not like a particular color so
that that needs to be kind of addressed
let's go ahead and change this to active
scene spheres though and then if the
closest sphere here is null pointer then
we haven't hit anything and if we
haven't hit anything what do we do we
invoke Our Miss Shader so we can return
Miss with that Ray okay and of course
Miss also returns a renderer hit payload
so this part of our kind of Trace Ray
function is really just responsible for
figuring out whether or not we've hit
anything and if so what is the closest
thing that we hit and what is its hit
distance that's all it does so moving on
here do we calculate origin and hit
point and all that stuff well not really
because that's going to be the job of
the closest hit Shader well the closest
hit function I'm really talking about
shaders now so really all we have to do
here is return closest hit and then we
provide Ray we provide the hit distance
and we kind of want to know the index of
the object we've hit now previously this
used to be closest sphere I don't really
want to pass in a sphere pointer into
this function I definitely could but I
would prefer to just pass in like an
index so what I'm I'm going to do is
actually refactor this so that it works
based on an index system instead we're
going to change this so that it's going
to be let's just do active spheres I
here and I'm going to rewrite this so
let's do uh so that it's size t i equals
0i is less than active C dot skills or
size I plus plus now we have an index
and a closer sphere here let's go ahead
and make this an INT so that it can be
negative one I don't think we're going
to exceed the size of an INT here anyway
you could make this like a size t or a
un32t in that case obviously since 0 is
a actually an actually valid index you'd
probably have to set it to like un32 Max
or like you know acid and numeric limits
Max or whatever which is just like FFF
lots of F's and then if closest sphere
is like equal to that you know you
haven't hit anything however we'll just
make use of negative one which is
technically equivalent to ffff if you
make it a unit but anyway uh that's
going to be our closest sphere so it's
now an index instead and then and over
here all we'll do is we'll assign
closest sphere to I like that and we can
cast it into an end just so that we
don't get any warnings back over here if
closest sphere is less than zero so it's
negative we know that we can just return
Miss because we've missed everything
otherwise we can pass in closest here
now and it will in fact be our index so
because we have made it an in so I'm
just going to go back here and change
object index in probably both of these
to just be an INT and null adjusted over
here as well and that's kind of it so
obviously everything under this return
here is going to be part of our closest
hit Shader because we're moving that
code into our closest hit function I
really do keep saying Shader so now we
need to look up what our closest sphere
is and we'll do that by just writing
const sphere and we can actually make
this a reference now instead of a
pointer we'll type in closer sphere and
we'll set this equal to active scene
spheres and then object index like that
and then we're going to have closer
sphere dot position and Dot Albedo but
again this this does not return a color
now this is getting a little bit into
the subjective design of how you want
this to work you can definitely
calculate like materials and colors and
everything inside a closest hit Shader
inside your GPU raytracing pipeline
however that's not the way that I prefer
to do things I prefer to just have
closest hit as a Shader that basically
will give you the required data that you
need from like the vertex buffer and
potentially like some other calculations
for that object that is your closest hit
and then back in the rage and Shader
where you launch those Rays you can then
look at the material and decide what you
want to do how to shade it as well as
whether or not you need to send out
additional rays and how and how many and
all of that stuff so in other words I
prefer to do all of my material stuff
and all of my actual shading inside that
original rage and Shader and just have
closest here return the data I need for
that that's kind of subjective of I
guess that's just my opinion on how I
like to do things you can obviously look
at this head payload in both our Ray
tracing Series code here but also inside
an actual payload you would have inside
your GPU Ray tracing shaders and just
add a color and then just return that
that's totally viable as well but that's
not how we're going to do things here so
instead what we'll do is we'll calculate
like the world position the world normal
and uh object index is just going to be
this and then also hit distance is just
going to be the hit distance so let's
build up a hit payload to return here
this will be our payload we're going to
type in payload.hit distance equals head
distance payload dot object index equals
object index and then we just need to
calculate the world position and the
world normal so the hit point over here
is already our kind of world space
position and this normal is our world
space normal so really we just need to
change this to be our payload World
position and then payload World normal
and then we can go ahead and change this
world normal to the normalized world
position the only thing here that we
need to adjust though for the world
positions remember because we did this
kind of Ray origin minus classic sphere
position we've kind of moved everything
back to the origin we need to make sure
that world position is actually kind of
translated by this sphere's position so
we need to add back that sphere position
over here if we do it earlier then that
will change the way we need to actually
calculate our world normal we'll have to
subtract the two vectors here but this
way since everything is based on the
origin here anyway we can just normalize
that existing World position together
World normal and then actually move the
world position into its correct World
position spot okay that's it that's all
of our payloads kind of set here or
rather all the data within our payload
so now there's just this calculation and
this calculation is the actual lighting
calculation which as I mentioned I like
to do inside this per pixel Shader which
is our rage and Shader
and perpixel function that's what I mean
so let's go ahead and paste that in now
we haven't actually called Trace Ray so
let's go ahead and actually call Trace
Rate with Ray like that that's the ray
that we've built up here and now we're
calling Trace Ray and then what we're
going to get back is this payload so
that's us calling Trace Ray receiving a
payload and now we can do everything we
need to such as figuring out the light
intensity by using the world normal here
and then also seeing what the sphere
color is by asking the payload what the
object index is and that of course is
the
that we've hit so we can just do active
scene
spheres and then object index and that
is in fact our sphere now obviously
before we do this we need to make sure
that we've actually hit something
because Trace Ray may have missed but
we'll do that in a minute so our sphere
color is going to be sphere.l beta like
that and then we can do our calculation
and return an actual color now what
happens if we miss well we know that we
call the Miss function which represents
Our Miss Shader and then really all we
have to do here is just create a payload
where the hit distance is like say
negative one and that's all I'm going to
do I'm not going to bother initializing
any of the other members here we're just
going to set hit distance to -1 and just
return payload and what that's going to
mean is back over here inside perpixel
if payload has a hit distance that's
less than zero then we can just return
whatever our kind of Sky color or clear
color should be so until now we've been
returning black so we're going to go
ahead and do that as well zero zero zero
and one like that and so it's important
here that obviously object index we
don't try and do this this kind of we
don't try and access this spheres array
with this index unless we're sure that
we actually hit something because it
won't be set correctly this only gets
set inside the payload over here now I
will say that we could like technically
change this a little bit so that we take
in like a payload reference here which
already has these two sets by the trace
Ray Shader however that's not exactly
how uh this would work in a GPU
retracing pipeline so I'm going to keep
it like this because this is this is a
lot more similar to that okay cool so
that's it
um we obviously have to return the
payload here though
embarrassing I almost forgot but that's
kind of it so we now clearly see what
happens if we hit a sphere what happens
if we miss a sphere and then finally
back in in per pixel we now have the
ability to sand out really as many Rays
as we want let's go ahead and make sure
this works first and then we'll we'll
test out multiple arrays Okay cool so
this looks exactly the same to me
performance I think is about the same I
must confess I didn't really look at the
performance before I
before I started making these changes
should be roughly the same it wouldn't
surprise me if it's a similar second or
too slower but there you go now let's
try something really really simple to
make use of this new kind of
architecture let's try and make these
spheres reflective I want to see each
sphere in in each other's reflection
before I do this go ahead and try and do
it yourself as a little exercise okay so
what we kind of want to do here is if we
do hit something so in the per pixel
function when we trace this Ray if we do
hit something we just want to trace
another ray but obviously we need to do
all of this code kind of per Ray that we
actually Trace so let's go ahead and
Surround this in a for Loop that's going
to go through this as many bounces as we
want which we're just going to set to
two for now
bounces equals two I've just named it
bounces so it's clear and we're
basically going to do all of this code
we're going to have a final color glm
vect3 color which I'm going to just set
to zero and this is going to be the
color that we return here at the end
once we have that sphere color what I'm
actually going to do is just add it to
our current color now there definitely
needs to be some multiplier on this
because otherwise we're just going to
keep making the image brighter and
brighter what I want to do is have some
kind of multiplier we'll set it to like
one for now we're going to multiply this
sphere color by this multiplier and then
I'm going to like reduce the multiplier
a little bit now this definitely isn't
physically accurate this is just to draw
something nice looking hopefully don't
worry we'll get into like energy
conservation and all that stuff in the
future now we need to do the same thing
with this kind of Sky color as well so
what we're going to do is I mean this is
just black so we don't really need to
add it however we can still kind of
pretend that we are maybe processing a
sky that way if you have an actual sky
color that's not black it will work so
let's just go ahead and set the sky
color here and and we're just going to
write color plus equal Sky color times
that multiplier and then we're just
going to break so that when we don't
keep kind of tracing Rays since there's
nothing to trace from so where is the
bounce because at the moment all we're
doing is running through this exact same
code twice well what needs to happen is
once we actually hit something over here
we've we've determined that we have in
fact hit something we need to go ahead
and actually change this Ray origin
array direction for the next bounce and
we can do that by simply moving the
origin to the hit position the hit
position is going to be inside the
payload so payload Dot World position
but we need to like move it a little bit
forward I'll illustrate why so if we
have a sphere here and we've sent array
in and we've got a hit position now it's
this little hip position in red if we
try and Trace array from this exact
position like we're kind of like inside
the sphere if we try and Trace another
ray we're kind of like within the sphere
that chord depending on like floating
Point Precision all that give us like
incorrect results because we'll be
colliding with ourselves with the sphere
so instead what we need to do is like
move ourselves a little bit forward
right because if we nudge ourselves
forward then we're not going to clutter
with ourselves if we're kind of going to
trace the ray like from this position
instead now obviously that's a huge
distance that we've moved forward by
we're not going to move forward that
much but that's basically like our
little normal bias because we're going
to move along the normal so outward by a
very very small amount and so to do that
we just add on the normal but like a
really really small amount like maybe
0.0001 and that should be enough that's
how new origin and our new direction is
going to be a vector that's reflected by
what we've just hit so if this is the
sphere we've come in like this we've hit
this we want to reflect it by this kind
of blue normal so this is the normal of
the surface we've just hit let's go
ahead and reflect it by this normal this
incoming camera Direction so that we
kind of get this out going to Direction
going that way so let's go ahead and do
that all that requires us to do is call
this reflect function we're going to
reflect the existing array Direction by
the world normal and that's it simple as
that so now we should be shooting out
two rays per pixel well assuming we hit
something and if we take a look at it
okay so we don't see anything here
what's going on we try and move these a
little bit closer I mean honestly it's
really like hard to see what may have
gone wrong here if you don't already
know however I did mention last episode
that we aren't quite evaluating our
closest T correctly because if you
remember what happened is if we actually
moved this back behind the camera it
like came around like this and the
reason that that was happening is
because we're allowing closest T to be
negative so what we need to make sure is
the closest T is greater than zero and
if closest to his lesson hit distance
then we can kind of treat it as the
closest hit if closest T is is negative
then that's kind of we should ignore
that result because that means the
distance from the camera is like
negative that doesn't make sense the
objects behind us so if we try running
it with this code just only processing
closest T if it's greater than zero then
you can see now we have a beautiful
reflection and we can play around with
this obviously we can see this sphere
inside here we can move around it's
still kind of real time you can see it's
a little bit struggling it's about 30
milliseconds for this resolution however
we do have a pretty nice result and if I
move this perhaps a bit down maybe make
it bigger and Center it it's kind of
like we have a little bit of a flaw
going on here now and so there you go so
you can see how cool this is now that we
have the ability to actually structure
our code with this kind of Trace Ray and
closest hit and miss function and that's
going to make it really easy when we
move this into the Vulcan Ray tracing
pipeline in the future thank you guys
for watching hope you enjoyed this video
if you did please don't forget to hit
the like button I think we're getting to
the point where where we can probably
start talking about materials and
lighting a little bit more seriously so
that's probably what we'll explore next
as always don't forget to check out
brilliant using my link in description
below and I will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]